what has happened in their citizens of
the reject Nation it is time for what
everyone is raving about being something
amazing even those who haven't seen it
yet but after last week's Cliffhanger I
am very much excited for it as I'm sure
in theaters all hail the cowboy hat like
you don't put it in theaters unless it's
truly cinematic how are you MJ Tessler
that's a social media handle at MJ Tesla
that's me I'm really jazzed I like went
back and played the world Between Worlds
episodes so I'm just like so jazzed
about this how are you doing Greg I'm
doing good it's been really busy around
here John ah great I've been I've been
soaking I don't have a good answer today
they use the force to leave a like today
guys and thank you to all I've been
watching our videos and continue to
encourage us to be open honest authentic
and whatnot I also wanted to say thank
you to all who have been purchasing some
shirts over at the rejectnationshop.com
real rejects have launched the merch
store and you got all these awesome
designs like the soccer shirt that I'm
wearing right now now the last daddy
sure which is a combination of you know
Mandalorian Patriot Pascal you get the
idea from looking at this image here
this one and then oh look at that one
and that one and there's even more and
now I got my sister on board to be like
a family operation where she's gonna be
doing some more designs for us but thank
you guys to all I've been showing your
support it's one of the best ways to
support the channel anywho guys uh let's
get into it
foreign
patreon page they could all be joining
let's do it
make us wait
it's fine do a full sweep and report
back Mom
[Music]
I said enough to help set them on their
path
[Music]
it's such a somber start I told them to
stay together oh poor guy don't blame
yourself
I think they did such a great job on the
expression of his eyes they never listen
filoni directed this one right he's got
that handle on the emotion like episode
one was absolutely to us too yeah
[Music]
oh
look at this music in them chills man
I know Warrior
okay it's Merrick
[Music]
done all the Clone War episodes you look
the same
you look old
well that happens women aren't allowed
to age you lost a fight
I don't remember
trust me
you lost
Palin skull yeah it's pretty
cool
so you do remember that's good why
still have a chance oh he's mentoring he
got a foot in the reality you got a foot
in life tell me what's going on
I'm here to finish your training yes she
said in the first episode he never
finished my train and reminded us of
that one is never too old to learn snips
this is good
this is very good what's the lesson
master
live
please
[Laughter]
or die
what exactly is he
I've heard that before
oh wow we're getting this
[Music]
oh
cool
[Music]
no just stay there final episode
oh gosh there's a lot of feelings right
now if that's the Aging too it looks
Exquisite I feel like I'm gonna enjoy
his appearance in this one episode alone
more than I did in Obi-Wan
I've got a thought Senator Organa says
she can only give us a cupboard for so
long oh God
if we stay out here any longer without
reporting in people are going to start
asking questions here's the forest Jason
we might benefit from people asking a
few more questions not if we don't have
any answers but mom there's something
about the water yeah yeah yeah you're
right
look music cute
pulls a broom out of nowhere Mom listen
I am no listen to the waves
General you said you wanted to be a Jedi
what are we listening for
it's obvious mom
servants and the waves the waves
crashing
no
the lightsabers oh wow dude you call
that early I didn't think it would
happen this episode
great sound design
[Music]
the emotional thrashing of waves
colliding with it too that's cool
[Music]
literal chills
felony you son of a
well done kid if you notice kanan's
pauldron on his side oh is it I didn't
catch it well we're doing it again Yang
you're with me in the ghost right away
she finally called it the ghost what am
I missing what just happened Jason has
was a Jedi
okay
[Laughter]
brilliant Carson man of the people you
know in uh
in the chest Ron species kids his age
they're called Skywalkers
[Music]
oh man Anakin in his prime I did not
expect them to do this
there's that's fair looks like you don't
have
enough to offer
[Music]
I haven't taught you everything yet
oh wow dang I call that the youngling
Slayer where are we going
the land of the mushroom where are we
going wait a second are we
sand I think sand hates that
my arch nemesis
is
[Music]
it Geonosis step back to the beginning
whoa cool
oh no whoa
[Music]
what a transition wow
is this for sure Geonosis no not 100
[Music]
but it's the uh yes it is this is an
episode of the Clone Wars yeah no
kidding wow
[Music]
you tell me
wow
wow wow
jog your memory correct that's your
problem
oh where can I see
Rex in the gate
this is
insane
stunts
this is your training
wow this is what I wanted like
so to be more about yeah I mean actually
about its Title Character
steam cameo
no but we are gonna get an age down
tomorrow
[Music]
oh then right off there's a Twilight
yeah yeah
early on in the war that makes sense
when I said one of their first bat the
first ones right and it's still
generation one armor too
go back
you know who that is it tracks come on
snips
I want to hear him speak it's Rex
come on speak is there a problem
we lost so many
hating Christensen turning into Austin
Butler and I love it yeah okay this is
so here for it oh mannequin Skywalker it
was my fault
they were following my orders I got them
killed
come here
she's always had a guilt complex his
Jedi it's our job to lead that doesn't
mean we don't make mistakes and our
mistakes cost lives that doesn't bother
you of course it does
that's got a Bill Skarsgard thing about
whatever else this isn't what I trained
for you must adjust to the times uh-huh
well Obi-Wan taught me we were keepers
of the peace to win this war
I have to teach you to be a soldier
this is so crazy
all I'll have to teach my own Padawan
one day huh yes that's the lesson she
needs to learn
do you even want a Padawan
you didn't you know teaching's not
always cracked up
let me tell you I'm joking you're joking
yeah a joke what would you prefer tell
me what do you want
you want me to be more serious it's so
perfect I'm teaching you how to lead
how to survive
and to do that you're going to have to
fight yes
I just love the full circle trajectory
of how this is the live action and
there's Clone Wars now this feels like
an adaptation of Clone Wars it's insane
it really really is also Rex say
something yes please
oh man this obscured into the
battlefield shots that he has yeah
Mr Tidings yeah
oh geez a wedding
is this all just a some type of like
conscious projection like from her I I
think it's a real lesson or you think
it's like actually Anakin if I figured
there's some damn that was like a poster
you see that yeah that was a poster shot
right there
I mean the pergola are still out there
that's one way to get to our destination
the new Republic is only a short
transmission away
I was surprised they changed their mind
and approved your mission
so they never changed their mind this
mission is unauthorized yeah
some general I am just gonna need help
that's what you're supposed to do you do
things your way because you care
this is why people like you let's call
some friends hey Yang where are they
people don't just vanish Into Thin Air
well no
normally no
I've seen this week always
especially with Lady Tano
tenacious tea so it was her master yeah
what was he like oh this is great
intense
[Music]
[Laughter]
chill a little older now no still yes
damn nice
it's the Battle of Mandalore the siege
ah bad on those moves too
relax
yeah now this is the end
it's right during order 66
oh yes
a live action wrecks
she's so young
the arm cross
oh he was not there no he was doing
something else I don't know what this
was the siege of Mandalore
we had parted Ways by now
it was
a warrior now
as I trained you to be
is that all what a great shot
gun within you will be everything I am
oh For Better or Worse just as I
inherited Knowledge from my master and
he from his
Legacy
Star Wars legacy but my part of that
Legacy is one of death and War but
you're more than that
because I'm more than that oh it's
feeling bored as Taco you are more
Anakin but more powerful and dangerous
than anyone realized this is where you
must resolve
d
is that what this is about
is that what you called me here you've
learned nothing back to the beginning I
gave you a choice
Boy live oh spread now huh
or die man
Greatest Hits incorrect record
oh they're gonna find themselves in the
in the temple sequence during their last
duel
oh boy
that is crazy I thought they slipped the
breath in there I was like when are we
gonna see this we'll get up again
this is great
oh my God
oh my God those eyes
[Music]
oh
strike me down
oh her eyes
[Music]
I choose to live
pallid
[Music]
I'm loving his performance
hey nice
There's Hope for you yet
[Music]
we never Gotta See Hayden Christensen be
the live-actions
I'm very much in all that I feel like
every time he shows no panel he's like I
gotta prove that I can be a good
performer in this role he's got nothing
to prove all he needed was a good script
and someone who can direct actors oh
it's about to be upside down water time
oh
stranger things oh soothing
foreign
[Music]
just lands right on her
oh my God it's Man of Steel
well done pilot
huge Kudos the team for Prosthetics that
can get wet like that yeah
look sick shot
I love the Ethereal operatic music so
much
well they actually gave Jason a
serviceable role instead of just a cameo
I wonder if now she can commune with
fourth ghost and I can
use the light again
hope a mortise the father said he was
like more than all that right it's it's
heavily implied I think at this point
that he is that Anakin's the father
she's the daughter
no we have not found her we were hoping
you could explain what happened
to see the makeup without her yeah so
now it's really well done
but I am aware it's makeup yeah
for the first time
her and Jason could use the force to
navigate their way there that's what the
chests do they could follow the Pergo
well that's what the chests will use for
sensitive youth to follow the the
difference the old way of hyperspace
travel oh I love her with a white look
going on oh my God she's become a soak
of the white yeah I rejoice
she's got the Gandalf Journey he did
lightsabers fighting with
I've been in a Starship before
Jedi Starship
we'll come along I'll show you the
training room I will train you you know
how to build a lightsaber yes can you
teach me no
she might have left an impression on it
like a memory
so we'll know what happened use the
force to see what happened
I love that works oh we're actually
gonna do it hell yes
yes
Force Echoes Cannon
oh it settles that
her taking on the white as well really
sets her up to be the daughter if that's
what they're playing I mean she's gotta
be
General we have a problem you always
come in here with bad news I'll deal
with this
you can work out a way to find something
how about a whale
[Music]
ring the neck that helmet used to be on
top of if I find you again
she couldn't say van again but
[Music]
um
What secrets are they about to deliver
for us
do you have evidence of Imperial Remnant
activity or of grand Admiral thrawn's
return either love you or you get on my
nerves there's nothing more I can do
it's just tied up in a bureaucracy of
Ruin me the Senate oversight committee
is going to determine if your command
should be permanently suspended
row you're going to need our testimony
to help you
sorry
I am not your only hope I don't know how
you score this but we're losing right
now
I know how to follow Sabine
what is about to happen
all right all right I just love the way
filoni directs like the first episode in
this one yeah he just gets it yeah he
really gets his his directing voice
really speaks to me
and the clouds and then how white they
are oh man
[Music]
oh wow wow
and it feels so gladly yeah
so ethereal
that one hop on that one go inside of it
Jonah and the whale it
what a great throw back to the original
trilogy
or is she gonna commune with him
let's go I'll give you 100 credits
do you want to buy some death sticks
wow
this is on a whole new level
hello there
wow are they mirroring shot of like the
center behind the frame showing her
growth you are a storyboard artist
felony
and whoever the storyboard artist was an
actual storyboard you're gonna have to
halt your approach to the planet until I
receive confirmation General has indeed
completed her mission Captain the reason
we are here is because there was no
mission above your pay grade I
respectfully disagree
explain the nature of this Mission or I
will see to it that you are stripped of
your Rainbow okay
but you're not gonna believe me
I'm really gonna talk to them
that's the idea
they're going to do a cool handshake
it's just like the stories you told me
how the whales together in the bad guys
far far away it's great gentle
Exposition they'll take Ahsoka to where
Ezra is
that's the
stuff there is hope she's really shining
this episode
I think the episodes are at their best
when it's like just focus on a couple of
characters sometime
this is such a great transformation
wow that's a scale
Godless details Jesus wow
come on in
[Music]
will the ghost be joining them hey
hey get in there
move us in
all right all right but you best come
back inside
no
no you'd want to look around wouldn't
you
okay with it
like how Ezra would do with animals I
know she's really expanding her
connection with the force yeah
[Music]
Chomper
your son they know where Sabine was
taken I have no idea what no idea
hmm
we'll just see where it goes oh she's
starting to really feel like as the
Ahsoka that we all kind of associated
with that's better than going nowhere
whoa yeah oh my God we just had to wait
for the arc like patient viewers yep
crazy right Captain Gerard this is
General sedula
yeah oh my God evasive maneuvers it
clear up their path
is the ghost in one of them yeah no I
don't think so
please let us see it please let us see
you travel
[Music]
wow wow wow
wow wow wow I had my doubts about space
whales and live action but man oh man
the Pergo
wow
sense of all
[Music]
same oh wow
oh let's go
is she gonna just try to keep up sorry
you can't make the trip that's all right
Jason's too young to travel between
galaxies season two
I'll find them
I promise oh May the force be with you
force be with you and also
wow
[Music]
wow ah yes
just end it just end it
well done well done that was great
beautifully done
it was the best episode easily sorry my
heart is beating so fast right now oh
yeah I've got the I've got the White
Knuckles what's the first thing you want
to talk about buddy I got several topics
here I'll just check off whatever you
start reading off
the performance
and the chemistry and the magic of
Ahsoka and Anakin and live action yep
like red started there elevated
elevated everything
um it was I feel like for Rosario Dawson
this was just the breakout episode where
it was an opportunity to like take an
extraordinary actor in the form of zero
Dawson give her an extraordinary acting
partner what I thought was a very
beautiful a very succinct script
um
there is a a magic between that
relationship that I think even fans that
haven't watched Clone Wars or Rebels
will now have an understanding of why we
love those characters together so much I
think beyond that this reconciliation of
this figure that in so many ways shaped
everything that she is and shaped the
world that she inherited and that she's
had to survive in
to confront that and to understand that
as as a Padawan who walked away from the
Jedi Order she never completed her
training
and to recognize that in order to
complete that training she needs to make
peace with her master and with herself
because
undoubtedly she feels responsible for
Vader's fall and
and and where I should say Anakin's
Fallen Invaders rise and there is just
this
this feeling of
for so long Star Wars has been
struggling to
figure out what is it
now
and this was the first time that the
focus and the clarity of what Dave
filoni and a whole group of amazing
creatives at Star Wars have been working
towards these past few years
um and I think it's it's become clear to
me uh where it's going and I'm I'm so
excited and I also just
you said it earlier uh and it's really
easy episode to episode to like get
grumpy that it's not there yet that it's
not there yet but I think the weight in
this case really did make the reward
feel all the more special
and weirdly enough there was that moment
when Ahsoka came back the gandalf-like
transformation which is just brilliant
uh
when she's looking at sabine's helmet
I felt more chemistry between those
characters now that she's had this
opportunity to go back and
I think remember what that Dynamic is
supposed to be and to understand that
yeah her master wasn't exactly a great
teacher himself but that that flawed
nature of the Anakin Ahsoka relationship
is also what can make the ahsokan Sabine
relationship so special and I think that
fear of her falling like he fell uh has
been holding her back so I'm just I know
I'm I'm like vomiting words right now
I'm just like emotionally moved at how
much they were able to capture in such a
short time and the actor that played
young Ahsoka I thought captured the
spirit of Ashley Eckstein and the
gravitas of Rosario Dawson in in perfect
fashion which for like a young actor in
Prosthetics in like a crazy War sequence
for five minutes is no small feat
um
it was magic
all right yeah okay what do you want to
talk about
that's conversation oh yeah sorry
all those words I Echo them as well
I mean this did have a really really
beautiful I mean being that more outside
viewer this really had a resilience of
energy on screen that was really
gripping and compelling and I loved the
way you know they bring back a lot of
characters and obviously we've seen
Anakin return for Obi-Wan and things
like that and you know sometimes it
feels more
like it's designed to be exciting but
it's not necessarily designed to be
meaningful whereas here it felt like
both it felt really kind of natural that
we would see Anakin in all these
different forms from across his timeline
but we're also seeing him through her
perspective and I love that reversal
towards the end of their exchange where
they have the fight with him in Sith
form his eyes are all red he's got the
scarring and stuff like that and then
after that you know emotional
breakthrough happens he sort of resets
and it's like an interesting way to look
at Anakin as a character because it's
easy to look at people and characters
like this especially as like a straight
line into your descent you know into
evil whereas you know this is kind of a
I thought it was a really great lesson
to be learned from teacher to student
that it is like yeah it's not just about
like how I turned out it's about the
totality of what I have given you and
even my end is a bit of teaching for you
you know and is a Telltale sign that you
could perhaps avoid in the future
instead of giving in telling to the fear
of that and losing yourself to the dark
side so yeah yeah like that
is felt like a very it felt like it
earned its gravitas I was like
effortlessly ripped by that and then
yeah traversing these different specific
battle moments and stuff like that like
these are the moments that then make me
go like yeah I would love to dive
further into these things you know
whereas previous episodes have had
references where I'm like yeah you know
it's fine yeah
um so yeah yeah I think that what Hayden
Christensen brought here was really
I think I was in awe of it because I
didn't exactly know what they were going
to be doing with him and I think they
managed to do something that was
multi-layered and also open to
interpretation I don't think you can it
is a conversation I would like to
actually have because there's this whole
you can't just I don't know sometimes
they have a line here or there that's
like here was Kanan he was a Jedi all
right cool there's this whole thing
about mortis and father son and daughter
that I don't know how you can just like
throw out a line to explain that to
General audiences because that's a whole
new can of force worms that you just
can't really uh just throw out there and
expect people to just latch at you right
away right and I think though if you are
aware of that that you can't interpret
okay maybe Anakin is this
um oh I mean you know this is her caught
between life and death right now this is
like a Purgatory ass World Between
Worlds can be a representation a
Purgatory it can be a representation of
that uh because you know like she wakes
up in the water and she's choosing to
live so it could just be something
simple as that and this is a
manifestation of going through her
subconscious and facing things and uh
these these certain traumatic memories
and trying to learn from those lessons
as well and revisit because a lot of it
is her revisiting stuff right with
Anakin so
what I was in awe of was how it managed
to be so multi-layered with okay you can
interpret Anakin on a multiple multiple
layers he could be the father for mortis
if you're familiar with that he could be
Force ghost Anakin working his way
through the because
because of what Clone Wars described on
that mortis Arc
he wouldn't be your typical Force ghost
plain and simple he just wouldn't be
that guy yeah that typical one shows up
and then the most the best part about it
to me though is Hayden Christensen we've
never got to see him do live action
mentor of the relationship with Ahsoka
and that is the heart of Clone Wars that
is the heart of why we loved Ahsoka was
that friendship that developed between
them and it was what was blowing my mind
I guess was who played him in Clone Wars
do you remember uh I don't remember who
played him oh God I'm so embarrassed it
was not hating Christians okay yeah it
was not hating Christians oh this is
going to stress me and while while there
were aspects that were supposed to
remind you of Hayden Christensen that
actor really did his own thing and the
writing really did its own thing as well
that helped fill in a certain type of
Gap but we never got to see Hayden
Christensen be that version that made
many of us love Anakin that much more
was his interpretation on that was that
interpretation on the show and we got to
see that relationship brought to life in
these Dynamics and sort of this like
ethereal ponderous sort of way uh but we
still got to see those interactions so
when he's saying like Snips when
he's actually saying it's not just like
Easter egg lines it feels like I'm
watching The Animated relationship it's
like
this weird full circle trajectory where
first the live action Hayden Christensen
cast okay we're gonna draw him in the
likeness of him he's gonna do some of
his own inspiration but really do his
own thing and I felt like Hayden
Christensen watched the animated show oh
of course and then adopted a lot of that
because his acting was not I mean like
when you see him in Obi-Wan he did a
good job but I didn't really feel like
we got too much new other than more
exploration of him being mad you know
being rageful and hurt
this was like oh man they're doing the
animated relationship and I thought that
was that was the part that I because
even if you haven't seen the animated
version
for Live Action you have not seen this
side of Anakin before yeah and and so I
think and it's the soft side that makes
his descent all the more that's what
makes a heartbreak yeah yeah
there was something that I don't want to
get lost in in all like there was like
so much in this episode
there was a spirituality with the force
that I haven't felt in a long long time
uh and part of the magic is is kind of
in what Anakin was saying about the
thread of Master and Apprentice
and this idea of Anakin's time as a Jedi
will forever be marked by the fact that
he was a Jedi who had to become a
general who fought in war who fell and
you have each of these I mean like I
know I like the other the other episodes
like name them all but you have Anakin
to Obi-Wan Obi-Wan who who offers so
much and from Obi-Wan you have Qui-Gon
who offers so much for quargon you have
Count Dooku who offers so much and and I
love that eventually you get to Rey who
gets it all yeah
so but it is the force is this thread
it's it's not the individual of this of
any of the Jedi it's it's what they pass
down to each other their failures their
successes their hopes their dreams their
fears their nightmares all of those
things
collectively create this like beautiful
beautiful thread and I think Ahsoka kind
of coming to terms with
he
who the times that you live in while
they Define your actions don't
necessarily to find you it gives you an
opportunity to to forge yourself into
something and and she's kind of been
stuck in this kind of permanent state of
War she was raised into this and
um I think for Ahsoka to like finally
reconcile and
spiritually come to terms with it I mean
it's like very much and I know like we
all instantly like Gandalf Gandalf but
like a very similar
these like Gandalf after he fell uh
uh you know uh with the battle Rock like
the amount of time like it didn't seem
like a lot like it was really quick but
it also felt like forever and he came
back and and there was this like in
understanding and at peace with you know
in his case theatari but in ahsoka's
case
I think she's really reconnected with
the force in the most uh authentic of
ways and I know everyone was grumpy when
Ahsoka didn't show up uh like she did in
Rebels with the the whole Gandalf the
White get up at the in the finale I
think this really clarified for us I
think this because on episode two I know
they're like for us I think when we
first saw it we thought they were just
paying homage to the ending of rebels in
episode two but this
um that everyone else was saying that no
that this is recontextualizing they're
redoing it and this only further drove
that home yeah well I I think it was I
think Dave filonian is infinite
Brilliance realized that this would be
an arc for Ahsoka that she needed to go
on throughout the course of the show
yeah and to begin her there would do an
injustice to her and yeah I mean it was
it was apparent that that was one of the
seeds they were planting and I think
where the dichotomy that uh as a viewer
I was running into was when it came to
information displacement focus and the
emotion underneath all that like I
always I understood everything that
happened in episode four and I overall
liked episode four I just was having a
difficult time connecting emotionally
with it the way how apparently the rest
of the world did uh
whoops I was having a difficult time
connecting with that yeah and and I feel
like okay there's something specifically
about the way filoni himself directs
where I mean it makes sense to me I mean
it's it's his show even with so much
time with these characters I mean nobody
intimately understands Ahsoka and Sabine
better than Dave filoni well even when
he's the one not directing he still gets
all the credit
and he gets all the criticism too
because they're all written by him yeah
the director is essentially honor
whoever the other director is the other
ones that most of the times that they're
just honoring trying to bring Dave
filoni's Vision to life yeah and then
you feel the full vision and scope of
this because there's there's perhaps
maybe in terms of the storytelling of
ahsoka's Arc here there's a part of me
that's like oh you know it would have
been cool to have like just a little bit
more just a conversation with it between
uh Ahsoka and Anna you just want to look
like cherry on top conversation maybe
that's kind of a maybe department for me
however I think what he ex excelled at
here was doing stuff visually tonally
and knowing how to communicate all that
of what's going on
admittedly on a gorgeous surface but
underneath the surface of what's going
on that you can actually understand oh I
get the trajectory that Ahsoka is going
on because it seemed like that was the
art that she was having ultimately go
down this problem this resistance with
Sabine having to train her and then her
expressing some you know uh uh Anakin
didn't finish training me
and um yeah there is a bit of
information I I can't help but wonder
about the people though that are not
familiar with Clone Wars I can't help
them I feel like they did such a good
job at
giving that part of the audience a
glance and an understanding of the
dynamic that being said why would she
but felony like I don't know what I'm
getting at is I understand why she would
blame herself yeah for Anakin's descent
and if you didn't watch Clone Wars would
you would you get why she wouldn't why
she would blame herself not yet but I
don't I don't I don't I don't think
we're done yet with that I do think
something that just kind of like hit me
like a brick while you were talking
Dave filoni's selection of Mandalore was
brilliant yeah because
in the siege of Mandalore you ready for
some poetry in the siege of Mandalore he
wasn't there yeah when she needed him
and when he needed her most yeah and
when sabine's family
desperately needed her on manual Ahsoka
wasn't there for Sabine and Sabine
apparently wasn't there for a second
that's true so you know I think um
the the real question is will we
continue through the progression of of
you know the series
see Ahsoka and Anakin continue that
training like I caught the sense
tonality wise that there's still lessons
to be learned I think to your point
about like the conversation as the
cherry on top if they had just had a
conversation instead of doing that
powerful visual storytelling it would
have felt great sure but it wouldn't
have been as earned as as now if Anakin
were to commune with her if she would
commune with Anakin or however it you
know
um I meant like everything they did and
also well that's what I'm saying I think
I think we're gonna get I hope so anyway
I think we're gonna get a a version of
that and in the same way of
uh when when Yoda tells Obi-Wan you know
you're going to commune with your old
master and learn how to part of me kind
of feels like Anakin's gonna teach
Ahsoka not just that but also
something that goes beyond just like
being a force ghost yeah and uh I wanted
quickly because what I what I thought
was really cool because I was gonna
spend so much time on Anakin and
everything what I really loved too was I
I did have a thought go okay is this
gonna dip now that we're done with
Anakin's part of the story and it didn't
uh it remained great and
I want to talk about Hera what I think
is really cool of what they've done with
Hera
for you guys who are not familiar
yeah they explained who Kanan was but
that was like the love story of of
rebels between Kanan and Hera
and you know on Kanan kanan's death is
one of the like is one of the most
heartbreaking parts of watching Rebels
it is a it is a Monumental moment and it
gets etched into your memory forever
once you experience it basically and
Hera was privy for that moment and
shortly before that saying like I love
you and everything wow she was pregnant
yeah pregnant and pregnant at all right
and
um
he dies in such a tragic way without her
getting to say goodbye
and what I think is they're doing so
well here with the depiction of Jason
who
wants to be a Jedi is clearly shaping up
to be like I want to go more down my
father's path right like you know all
these things is that you they're doing
such a great job of that even though she
didn't get to have that goodbye Kanan
gets to live on through Jason and
keeping that connection and that
relationship evolving and what they're
developing with Jason which a lot of
time I feel like I would not actually
there's like this depiction or Jason I'm
like I feel like in other in some kind
of there's some alternate execution of
this and I would not enjoy but but I'm
really I really enjoyed it yeah like I
thought it was again it all comes down
to execution and tone for me and and
then of course that deeper context of
understanding what Jason is representing
and and Hera as well like the I really
loved
um
I got because like there were people who
were saying that they thought you're
Mary Elizabeth Winstead's performance
episode four was like the best she's
done and
there were people who are saying that
and I I don't agree with that I loved
her performance here though in this
episode she really really found it and
not just found it but captured like the
Nuance of like I always thought hero was
such an interesting character like she
is
in so many ways
a lot bigger of a deal than like uh
Rebels let her be like in my like like
because we're always so focused on the
Jedi side of things we forget like she's
like the daughter of this like crazy
like Rebel leader
um you know fought during the Clone Wars
she literally helps build the rebellion
in its infancy she's so complex and she
constantly juggles this like
she has to put it all out there and be
so vulnerable and I feel like we really
got to see that and I can only imagine
and I and I I felt it in this episode
both the pride and the fear that comes
with your child taking after his father
who is a Jedi now I'll tell you what I'm
excited for I want to flash forward and
see Freddie Prince Jr play
because he did such an amazing yeah it'd
be so cool to you know but it's It's
Curious like where is that gonna go like
are we gonna see that character's future
I hope he's not at the Jedi Temple when
kylo has his meltdown like I hope he is
that'd be hilarious
I hope that's the end of that's the
ending post credits yeah yeah yeah I
want you to meet someone this is to kylo
all right I do I do think what should be
noted
for like expanded universe fans
um
there is
Jason solo and that whole story arc like
obviously Dave filoni has a love for the
expanded universe and stuff that got cut
out you know when when Disney bought the
the property
um I'm curious if they're gonna try to
pursue some of those story Arts
um which would make sense because
thrawn's involved and you know we'll see
we'll see
um the the Pergo the Pergo we got to
talk about that uh
I mean we all saw that coming right yeah
but but the way we got there felt it
didn't land in a perfunctory or rote way
it didn't just seem like they had to do
it that way like they've been setting
that up how disappointing would it be if
we didn't do it all that set up with the
purple this is the whole time
and we never decide yeah what do we
travel via through them you know can you
imagine if we never did that but they
earned it that way I I mean I loved the
whole
um I love the whole idea that
she had to get more in tune with herself
but in chance getting more in tune with
the force which is what allows her to
connect with the Pergo to be able to
travel like literally be like hey can
you fly me you know because they were
just hybrid they were just like floating
around and she needed to communicate
with them like I need you to take me and
the fact that she was able to do it uh
that way instead of hopping like like uh
um what's it called like when you they
did it like they've done it in rubble
already like land on to them oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah instead of just like hot
day no well it's getting a train it was
part of this like continued theme of the
episode where
we're diving into a different side of
the force
we're we're really like the force Echoes
when she was remembering what like the
conversation was was being like which
you've seen in like Fallen ordering yeah
well that's exactly like we've we've
seen it in other places but we've never
seen it live action we've never seen it
canonically uh uh and I think it's
getting to the spirituality of this
character which is something that I
always loved about Ezra's character and
something that they explored with him
um that's on our thing too is the most
Soca focused episode and I think that's
why I loved it the most too well it
needed this was just so focused I I
stand by like the flashback sequences to
the Clone Wars I think really
were like the perfect demonstration of
why it would have been really nice to
see at least like a moment of uh Ahsoka
and Sabine while their relationship was
good
like like I know it's heavily implied
and that's like the one thing that I I'm
and yeah and I know that we'll see what
it will be by the end of this and I'm
sure it will be amazing I just wish I
don't think it's I don't feel like it's
I love this episode I'm not gonna sit
here and be like it's absolved of the
other things that I am concerned about
though like this like I I'm still not
that connected to the Sabine and Ahsoka
relationship yeah as much as I would
like to be I understand the context we
can obviously break it down be like yeah
this this poetry runs but like we can do
all that
um it's more about what is the show
doing to communicate the relationship on
screen and how much of a feeling am I
generating from this you know so that
and that is such a main thrust of this
show so yeah but I know you wanted to
say something well no I mean this
doesn't yeah absolve some of the gripes
from previous episodes but this did feel
like the most fully realized and like it
managed to draw out a proper balance
between the deliberate Pace they've been
going for but all also with having it
feel like a good amount of things are
developing and even though things happen
gradually they seem to happen with that
sort of magical sense of design around
the periphery where you can have a
growth of character within Ahsoka that
feels like it makes sense with
everything that came before but it also
feels quite rewarding when it's like oh
yeah like part way through when she
comes back out and she's in the white
she's got a whole other enchantment to
her personality there's just like a
growth of that and even the thing with
the Pergo has this like spiritual
feeling quality and everything in the
world Between Worlds has its spiritual
quality to it even with Jason listening
to the waves the sensory qualities the
elemental like this did a good job for
me of putting you wherever it was
putting you in a very lucid way much
more than the previous ones have done
where I've been kind of looking at an
arms distance at some interesting stuff
and waiting for it to really like hook
into my spirit so to speak and this uh
managed to do that in understated ways
you know most heavily stated with Ahsoka
and Anakin and all that but in
understated ways with kind of everybody
and this was the first time it felt like
even though you know people were on
different missions and story lines and
stuff like this does now feel like an
ensemble here in this moment and uh and
yeah like the the journey feels like
there is both excitement Adventure hope
and Peril on the horizon and it just
feels like you can extrapolate so much
more out of it than just kind of sitting
and going okay cool a couple things
happened but I don't feel you know as
moved connected or otherwise like this
managed to like feel like sequentially
naturally the next episode and yet also
feel like it has all the things that
have been messing up until now
um and lastly uh great Thai super fights
yeah terrifies for great yeah um
hurricane back to the prequels
um and the way they did that and I I
really I like these lightsaber fights
the way they were shot more than
again like I liked the last episode I
just wasn't in love with it like
everyone else and people were really in
love with those lightsaber fights and I
thought they were good but I I feel like
this was an ex I thought this was better
I'll just say that like I'm not
interested I think that episode five
versus four but I thought this was a
really sharply executed I think part of
it's the emotion that goes into that's
exactly like that's exactly you know I
two of them yeah no the two of them just
have such like there is history and with
every strike of the blade you can feel
it
um you know whereas with like Bailey it
was beautiful I mean he's doing this
like European medieval style and
ahsoka's doing this you know
samurai-esque that's cool mood and all
yeah yeah it's cool but well I'm super
this was evocative not just Moody yeah
well I I think uh ideally we'll get the
best of both worlds let's hope so
um either way I'm so excited hey what
did y'all think I feel like the
internet's a buzz right now uh thanks
for keeping us on track no but no I'm
I'm serious I want to know that I really
appreciate and I know last week
we got some heat
[Music]
I don't know
I love it people brought up some really
great things next weekend suck and I'll
be honest about it
if it sucks
it was it was magic uh and you know what
I thought this was great this is magical
and this this is um this is what happens
with patients and when you give
creatives the power to do what they do
yeah you were ending this
so leaves leave the force all right
behind you we gotta go I gotta edit man
use the force to leave a like And
subscribe all right bye
[Music]